how's um resumes welcome back to phase
Ray all the bishop's to the left all the
[ __ ] to the right all the [ __ ] say
ah ha
best face rig ever that's all I can name
little booty had me honey like Mao oh
wow
oh this is some creepy [ __ ] man oh my
god ah
I wanted happy my face ly it's not a
little knob supposed to be your dick oh
yeah it's my damn yeah oh oh my damn my
jab Lowell I put this on my I put this
on my sandwich
so y'all know me still say mochi but I
big okie hate it all bad rotis is we
know she cheats no trails and no cheese
no feelings and don't please
nope toast oh stop no girls in those
heels touch nowadays everybody wanna
talk like we got something to say but
nothing comes out with the room to live
just a bunch of gibberish and what the
[ __ ] effects differ gotta buy trade so
what are you saying is something better
you hate oh oh oh oh oh this is my jam
this my just tame yourself from marriage
overboard
you don't save yourself from marriage
you're a horrible person
it's got what it takes
so tell me why can't this be love
straight from the heart it was all
[ __ ] from the day that I finally did
hey Chacko me flop a new please baby
push oh I'm trying to make me some dope
now get your man to answer good
wonderful can work in his land and then
maybe I'll blow but new you want to be a
little [ __ ] about it
thought that I would never do [ __ ] about
it made a contract with a twist around
it so I can never ever pass the airline
life been treating you night it wouldn't
say
go [ __ ] royal oh man take a look at
yourself here I live you treated your
life it wasn't good night and what's too
bad but you can't get close yet and my
in here tonight
can't they see me rolling day ten
patrolling and tryna catch me ridin
dirty shutter catch me ridin dirty gotta
catch me ridin dirty awake in the
morning tired of sleeping get in the
shower and make my bed out alone I put
on my makeup open your eyes
let's see my eyes are [ __ ] missing out
this song
Oh God not anything but this song first
thanks works on my burger duck into the
mirror I'm ready for a new day without
you and I smoke steady on my feet I talk
my Porsche beats me hold on to the night
I will be the change
ah wait I want to be with you and
make-believe I'm a [ __ ] walking
hamburgers no I'm not I go out at night
sleep without the lights and I do all
the things I had to keeping you up my
mind when I think I'll be alright
I am always wrong I don't want to
started dancing in this mirror singing
in the shower lobby la da da la da da
that's how I cut them up cut them up cut
him up come up I don't be giving the
[ __ ] a dead but it's in the
trunk time to get in the truck you don't
want it understand [ __ ] again try to
break whatever peace out oh oh some a
little duma lamaa you assuming i'm a
human what I gotta do to get it through
the supermoon innovative and I'm made of
rubber so that anything if you take a
ricochet chameleon video I was a great
Eliminator long victim I why the [ __ ]
you tell me
[ __ ] must think I'm a [ __ ]
dummy because address poetry sting
camera shame wine rody I made a lot of
money
alright Bryce I got after that episode
that I had a [ __ ] ton of fun doing this
and so that's all what matters that you
believing like on this episode bros I
really appreciate it and that's all for
me for now as always stay awesome